there's a problem with art and with
filmmaking and with acting and with it
and the problem with it is that it's
cool and it's perceived as cool and
that's a problem because sometimes it's
cool sure but that's not what it is you
know what I mean like it's a job you
don't go into it because it's cool you
know and a lot of people do go into it
because it's cool and when you say oh I
do it because I'm an artist and I want
to do it this way like that sounds cool
but that's not what it feels like I'm
always hoping people will say well ask
me what's the worst advice you've ever
gotten and to me the worst advice I've
ever gotten I think is do what you love
and the money will come automatically
that is [__] Preposterous I wasted 15
years doing that and it's not the [__]
true like everyone needs money that's
everyone needs to have money unless
you're born with it and you still need
it you really have to prioritize and
understand that making money is a is a
skill and is a craft that's not
automatic very intentional and you have
to go after and do it